はぁ はぁ はぁ はぁ はぁ
【寒そうなはじめ】
寒い
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
あっ Twitter見ましょう
文房具かー
ちょっとまた 見ときます！
はい というわけで
今日なんですけども
なんか最近 親分がですね
スーパーの話を動画にしてたんで
まったく別なんですけど
あのー 僕がYouTuberになる前ですね
みなさん僕 何してたか
知っていますか
あの 僕 大学生をしながら
バイトをしまくっていました
実はね
で そのバイトをしてたんですけど
まあちょっと そのバイトの頃のね
ちょっとお話とかをして
みようかなって思います
たぶん みなさんの中でも
バイトをしてる方
しようとしてる方とか
いっぱいいると思うんで
まあ なにかの参考になればいいかな
っていう感じで
ちょっと俺のバイト話でも
聞いてくれや！
僕ですね 一番バイトで
頑張ったてたのがですね
コンビニです！
バカにすんじゃねえええ！！
してなかったらいいんですけど
コンビニのバイトっつったら
なんかバカにされそうな気が
するんですけど
まあ 僕もバカにしてたところは
ありました
僕 人生で初めてのバイトが
コンビニでした
理由は
だってそうでしょ！
なんかコンビニの店員さんとか
バイトとか見たら
なんかこうピッピッってやって
こうやって
「あざした！」ピッピッ「あっした！」
「したっ！」「あっした！」
「あっ、さーせん！」「あさした！」
みたいな感じで
なんかすげえ誰でも
できるんじゃねえかなと思って
コンビニのバイトを始めました
大学1年生の夏ぐらいから
バイトを始めました
なんかね あの サークルも
ろくに行かず
なんか部活をしているわけでもなく
ヘラヘラっと大学1年生を
過ごしてたんで
バイトしなきゃ！
と思ってあの 始めました
いやー コンビニなんて
ちょろいっしょ！
楽勝でしょ！
と思って入ったんですけども
なんの巡り合わせかは
よく分かんないですけど
僕がその働き始めたコンビニがですね
全国的に見て 全国的に見て
なんかすごい
有名なコンビニだったらしくて
サービスと接客の あの なんか
模範店みたいな
研修とかでビデオ見せられるんですけども
そのビデオで映ってた女の人が
もうその店で働いてたりしてて
うわ 俺 えっ？
えっ やばい！
とか思いながらなんかそういう
ちょっと接客レベルマックス最強の
コンビニで
僕 働き始めることに
なっちゃったんですけども
初日そのコンビニでバイト行って
なんかそのお姉さん？
お姉さんと一緒に
バイト入ったんですけども
なんにも分かんないんでとりあえず
そのレジピッピッてしたやつを
袋に入れてくださいって言われて
こう袋に入れた瞬間
もうめちゃくちゃ怒られて
何してんの！！
おかしいでしょそれ！
って怒られちゃったんですよ
怖かったな
で それ なぜかというとこうなんか
おにぎりとかいろいろ
あったんですけども
入れる順番を間違えちゃって
なんかおにぎりが潰れちゃいそうな
入れ方してたから
怒られたっていう
今 考えたらすげえなんか
普通のことだなって思ってたんですけど
初めてのバイトだったんで
なんか そういうことが
まったく分かんなくて
コンビニのもの
袋に詰めることで怒られ
服装で怒られ
髪の毛赤くしたときも怒られ
下駄 履いてバイトしよう
と思ったときも怒られ
仕事が遅くて怒られ
レジでんき(?)をミスって怒られ
声が小さくて怒られ
もう ほんとに
コンビニってこんなに怒られんの
っていうぐらい
めちゃくちゃ怒られました
結構 萎えてまして
ほんとばっくれてやろうかな
とかめちゃくちゃ思ったし
厳しさに給料が見合ってなかった
って思ってて
時給何円だっけ あのとき
確か730円とかかな
もうめちゃくちゃ安い給料で
俺はなんでこんな怒られながら
やってんだろって言いながら
それでもやっぱ
お店のブランドを守るために
怒られたことちゃんと聞いて
怒られて怒られて怒られて
3ヶ月も死ぬほど怒られて
3ヶ月後にだいぶ
ちょっとこう馴染んできて
ある程度 そのお店のバイトとして
ちゃんとちょっと動けるように
なり始めたかなっていう感じでした
もうすごいんすよ！
あのコンビニってこうなんか
お客さん入ってくるじゃないですか
あのー よくいる
あの普通の店員さんだったら
なんかしながら
「あっ いらっしゃいませー」
「いらっしゃいませー」
って言うんですけど
僕の働いてたコンビニはもう
いらっしゃいませ
ってこの腕をこうして
こうするんですよ！
お客さんがレジの前に来た瞬間
ずっとこうやって「いらっしゃいませ」
ってもうやってましたね
それぐらいもう接客に関してはほんとに
なんかめちゃくちゃ厳しくて
もう背筋もピンとして
こういうお辞儀をして
「ありがとうございました」
「からあげクン増量中です
いかがでしょうかー？」
「いかがでしょうかー？」
「いらっしゃいませー」
「ただいま なんこつ入りつくね棒
20円引きです いかがでしょうかー？」
「いかがでしょうか？」
ていう感じで
めちゃくちゃバイト頑張ってました
そうだからね
なんかそういうのを見てると
なんか他のコンビニに行って
店員さんがなんか
チャラチャラやってると
「まじお前」
「ちゃんとやりゃー！」
って思っちゃうわけなんです
ていうですね
ちょっと舐めてコンビニに行ったら
そのコンビニの店員さんの
大変さというか
極めれば極めるほど
コンビニっておもしれえな
って思ってきてたのが
まあバイトの始まりでしたね
なんかコンビニって
ゴミ箱ついてるんですけど
もう ゴミ箱が溢れることはまずないです
溢れる前に絶対なくすし
たとえば こう
商品が並んでるとするんじゃないですか
ここ通路ね こうやって商品が
並んでるとするじゃないですか
お客さんが何か1個 買うと
ポテチとかだったら
これちょっと空いちゃうじゃないすか
この隙間をお客さんが商品を買って
「ありがとうございました」つって
ドアから出てった瞬間
急いでここまで行って
ポテチを寄せて前に出す
これ 前陳 といいます
この前陳作業を必ずやってました
商品をきれいに見せたいんで
じゃがりことか取られたりして
この場所が空いてると詰める
この作業を欠かさずやっていました
たぶん 最強レベルで
しっかりしたコンビニだったな
って僕は今だと思ってます
なんで僕 なんか大学卒業して
その一般企業に就職しないで
まあ YouTuber やらせて
もらってるんですけども
2年間以上か
約2年間以上コンビニで働かせてもらって
なんだろう その接客というか
人に対する接し方というか
サービス業というか
ちゃんと社会には出てないんですけど
ある程度の社会性は
身につけられたのかな
って思います
なんか ちゃんと働くって
こういうことだよ
っていうのを身につけられた
ような気がします
もう普通に10連勤とかしてましたからね
コンビニにいる方が長いみたいな生活が
あったときもあります
なんかね バイトはね
その楽して稼げるバイトとかも
いっぱいあると思うんですけど
苦労しても安かったバイトの方が
僕は自分のためになったかな
って思います
人としていろんなことを
磨いてもらえたかなって思いました
なんであのー
すごい厳しかったしクソ怒られたし
なんでコンビニバイトで
こんなクソ怒られたんだろ
って思ったんですけど
僕は今 すごい感謝しております
プロの証みたいなのがありまして
僕そのサービスマスターっていうのに
選ばれたんですよ
全国の店員さんでも限られた人しか
それなれないらしくて
なんかそのコンビニの本社の人の
抜き打ちでそれに奇跡的になれまして
その全国のコンビニの店員さんのその
スーパークルーだけをこう集められて
研修みたいなのがあったんですけど
あの ディズニーランドで
ディズニーランドって
サービス業のなんか
頂点なんすよ
ディズニーのキャストさん達って
ほんとにすごくて
もう来てくださった方を
みんな絶対幸せにして帰そう
っていう気持ちでお仕事してるんすよ
なんであのサービス業
接客の頂点っていうか
もう模範にしたいといえば
もうディスニーランドとか
ディズニーシーとか
ああいう場所になってて
全国のトップクルーで集められた
研修っていうのは
ディズニーランドでの研修だったんすよ
何人か静岡県の代表として僕が選ばれて
ディズニーランドに行って
全国のそのトップ
コンビニ店員さんたちと一緒に
ディズニーランドの研修を
受けさせていただいたりもしてました
そういうすごい安くて
辛かったんですけど
まあ やっててよかったな
って思えたこともありましたよ？
ってな話です
まあ 逆にそれが裏目に出たときも
あったんですけどね
なんかコンビニで働いてて
バイト入りまくってて
10連勤とかしてると
毎回来る人とか分かるんですよ
「あ 毎日この人来るな」
「毎日この時間に来るな」
「あっ あの人あのタバコだな 42番だな」
「ハイライト！」っつって
こうやって「ハイライト！」
ふっ
ふふっ
なにやってんだか
そういうなんか
常連さんがいるんですけども
なんかある日
めちゃくちゃ入ってたときに
めちゃくちゃかわいい女の子が
来たんですよ！
YEAH!
めちゃくちゃかわいい女の子が来てて
「あ、かわいい…
ありがとうございました！」
で なんか次の日もこうやって来て
「あっ… いらっしゃいませ！」
3日目「いらっしゃいませ！」
めっちゃ来るんすよ！
めっちゃ来てくれてて
やばい！
なんかコンビニのバイト、楽しい！
って思ってたんですけど
ある日 そのお客さんの
こうお会計して帰ったあと
なんかもう1回戻ってきて
なんかレシート持ってたんですよ
で レシートを急に僕に渡されて
「すいません！」
「連絡先教えてください！」
って言われたんですよ
「生きててよかったぁ！」
って思ったんですけど
ほんとにコンビニに忠誠を誓ってまして
お店のことしか
もう考えられなかったんで
すっごい教えたかったんすよ！
連絡すごい取りたかった！
めちゃくちゃもう連絡聞かれたとき
めちゃくちゃ嬉しかったんですけども
「申し訳ございません 業務中ですので」
と言って断りました
チクショー！！
【ED】